e la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo su un gioco
stranissimo insieme a death and roll in
teoria poi non lo so si guida in questo
gioco si guida non so neanche capace
infatti facciamo un quiz veloce che
cazzo resto semaforo questo sì ma tutto
questo non è un semaforo ma il cartello
che però va bè quello sono scemo con un
altro discorso cartello significa
tabaccheria c'è una tipa e noi strada
chiusa o e tabaccheria dove sta vivendo
bene visto che ancora non ho salve e la
madonna che cazzo ne so io fai le aree
ciao nonna così si è finalmente arrivato
mio caro puoi venire più vicino se vuoi
non ora grazie non bastava pochissimo
anzi verrà sto proprio bene forse la mia
presenza tip spa vennero allora no per
carità di dio cioè solo un po di occhi
bianchi ma credo sia l'effetto della
cocaina era nonna non c'è niente di cui
aver paura figliuolo lei cercando le
istruzioni del rituale sia ecco è questo
che di solito i visitatori che vengono
qua mi chiedono aiuti devo chiedere
delle rituale ma in realtà io penso
fosse un gioco per patenti nel senso che
per guidare è vero che il rituale al
potere il potere di di garantirti un
desiderio grande cazzo mi chiama patente
subito mai a compiere un rituale poi
torna da me a e porta con te le seguenti
cose un libro una campana è una candela
del wii shop
quindi possiamo iniziare
ricominciamo che bello bene charlie
charlie charlie sei qui compie rituale
con tasti direzionali va bene ho fatto
io non ho capito niente di quello che ho
appena fatto regalano capito niente però
ok
qual è la tua richiesta dei poteri
oscuri a devo scrivere come si dice in
inglese patente che ne so patente allora
non lo so na bella [ __ ] fig
no ecco tre milioni di iscritti e non ci
stà iscritti big money cos'era
l'anomalia e book giusto bel no salve io
vorrei una patetica tantum verde alla
gola torna a posto di cazzo succede ma
perché sta andando a su scappa e la
macchina non lo sarà ho detto io che era
un gioco di macchine questo meno gli
tutti gli horror non sono così no no
cazzola parte sbagliata parte sbagliata
davanti atti c'è una civetta di alle
botte finta non va di vila che ci stanno
gli spiriti salve sebbene vede anche lei
del rosso per caso buongiorno signor
camionista non è che per caso sta
vedendo anche lei cose strane ragazzi è
l'unico gioco della storia perché un
bidone appena cascato sul mio paraurti
che cazzo succede ma sei scemo ma quanto
sei stupido già ben ma va a cagare ho
investito una persona mi è arrivato un
bidone e ho fatto un incidente c'è
fantastico certo che ce lo ha la patente
sono proprio pronto per questo se tutti
i videogiochi horror fossero così della
serie dopo aver preso uno spavento e
scippi la macchina e te ne vai sarebbe
fantastico da quando faccio gli horror
games che fa sta roba è questo
potresti mettere gianni morandi per
favore che mi dà fastidio questa cosa
brutto deficiente così cosa aveva quello
nel bagagliaio e l'ace privato idonei
tentano di uccidermi cosa ho fatto io i
bidoni di male non so se quella roba lì
a il tempo
salve permesso di guidare per caso le
scatole non ho capito dove siamo
arrivati siamo arrivati in una città non
ho letto non ha fatto in tempo a vj al
volante pericolo costante sara ma qua
ormai è un must e ragazzi lo sanno tutti
sono arrivato a 0
ever ville turn left ha quindi devo
andare a ever ville i seguenti posti
dovrebbero essere aperti mentre mi segue
il demonio in persona vado dal
supermarket a comprare la pasta a mia
nonna che cazzo sta succedendo perché mi
sono fermato ad un supermarket quando mi
segue anche gesù tanta soda devo morirci
di solito un dollaro perfetto della
cioccolata anche questa tanta grazie
perfetto io me ne andrei grazie è molto
gentile
adesso la cioccolata e la soda e posso
divertirmi league ce ne andiamo
sono tornati in macchina fantastico
quindi adesso ripartiamo è cessata na di
nuovo che si nota allo drugs and drug
shire andiamo a drug shire che non so
che cosa sia ma non ho idea fatemi
capire quando io arrivo in città
satana non mi segue più cioè si ferma
anche lui al supermercato e fa un breve
mi scusi scusi signora non volevo
investirla il figlio è stato un
incidente colpa di satana colpa di
satana se qualcuno magari mi fa fermare
da qualche parte che io già non so
guidare normalmente in più piove in più
mi segue il demonio vestito la cosa più
brutta che ho visto in tutta la mia vita
mi spiegate chi è che mettessero una
galleria giorno
a sono visioni porca [ __ ] così evitato
privati alla prossima città che è trash
art arlef negozio antico
ovviamente ci segue il demonio e andiamo
a visitare il negozio antico si tagli
capelli fa veramente cagare una bibbia
che mi serve assolutamente quindi
compriamo una bella sigrun cassi 17
termine per una bibbia deve farli
proprio bene gli esorcismi perché sono
concas la guida turistica alle lim non
ho capito il perché di sta roba ma va
bene già che ci sei visto che la bibbia
puoi mettere a radio maria
c'era uno che faceva l'autostop io torni
indietro io torni indietro anche veloce
thorne che troverò c'è cosa fa a quello
scemo che ha buttano tutti in contromano
dov'era il tizio dell'autostop cosa è
successo
cos'è sta roba tra migliaia la cassa
quattro famiglie era a casa quattro
ragazzi c'era uno che faceva l'autostop
non lo vedo più
ma se vado ancora indietro credo di
finire negli inferi quindi vadano avanti
e faccio prima a radio maria abbiamo
appurato che non funziona
ovvio cesa agent ai minimi in faccia che
brutta frase da un attimo allora io vado
è sì già già già non vedo un cazzo che
manca solo che mi metto a guardare la
guida turistica
ecco infatti ora devo chiamare dalla
norda onlus poi andiamo a walk tutto
sinistra ma devo fare qualcuno ha
scoraggiato perfetto non vedo un cazzo e
paris hilton che ci andata troppo di
profumo regaz a perfetto nuovo anno
aprire spegne st radio che se la musica
di la manzoni a questa non so perché mi
ricorda troppo la musica dei krypi pasta
rega altro che io possa accendere
spegnere le luci all'interno all'esterno
è bellissimo
se non ci fossero i demoni sarebbe
ancora più bello questo gioco peccato
nord a loro siamo arrivati credo spero
se la vita e mezza per arrivare 40
il
[Musica]
sono annessa canzone mi ricorda tipo
o anche sbattuto fantastico ma quindi se
bocci e verso ca [ __ ] tua sorella
[ __ ] li mortacci tua
devo fare per forza si
date a cagare ragazzi dato il problema è
questo se quando muoio e faccio ies è
data mi fa ripartire dall'inizio prima
che arrivi ad ed android ciao proprio
non ci arriverò mai nella vita
ciao ragazzi non provi l'episodio perché
è diventato alquanto inquietante solo
ero qui sopra di vedere che cosa c'era
dentro
spero che vi siate 100 ragazzi conclude
episodi a casa dice mi è piaciuto
sull'argomento è un mi piace anche la
pace di facebook e cavani descrizione
suggestivi scatti ci vediamo al prossimo
video ragazzi
[Musica]